[Music]
for many young fans actors are true role
models especially they're involved in
charity work
and also happen to embody their favorite
superhero
in this episode however we want to take
a look at the other side of the coin and
introduce you to 10 actors
with whom no one really wants to work
anymore
while the reasons for that are diverse
they're mostly related to lifestyle and
a general lack of kindness
so have fun with our latest kino jack
originals episode
even before two and a half men charlie
sheen was not at all known as a pleasant
work colleague
his career began in the 80s with
classics like ferris bueller's day off
and major league
after a few films in the 90s the
broadcast of two and a half men began in
2003 which finally made shane a well
known
and above all the best paid series actor
in the world however his life apart from
acting has been
anything but glamorous as he allowed
himself bizarre freakouts and strange
statements in addition to massive drug
abuse
especially these insults to the producer
chuck laurie caused warner brothers to
part ways with him in march 2011.
sheen is also said to have been anything
but a gentleman to his partners for
instance he fired a shot into the arm of
his
then fiancee kelly preston and his later
wife denise richards also eventually
left him due to threats of violence
steven seagal is probably remembered by
most as a quirky martial arts fanatic
his area of expertise is aikido a
japanese martial art that is actually
emphasized defensively
and here we are already at the first
point of criticism because many
adherents of his martial arts see
clear contradiction between aikido and
the action-packed hollywood movies in
which the techniques are
not at all displayed defensively sigel's
main problem however seems to be his
treatment of fellow actors
for many years allegations have
persisted that the 68 year old not only
threatened the film crew with beatings
but also physically attacked them
actor john leguizamo even claims that
after laughing at something seagull said
he was assaulted and thrown against a
wall he's even said to have broken sean
connery's hand once in a pre-training
session
truly not a nice fella and a well-earned
place on our list we think
in the early 90s everything looked like
the young and aspiring actress lindsay
lohan would have a blossoming career
ahead of her
today however the name lindsaylone is
more associated with escapades than good
movies and for good reason
multiple conflicts with a law in the
early 2000s and unprofessional behavior
on set put the actress on the back
burner relatively quickly
her police file is bulging with drunk
driving hit and run and drug possession
violations
no wonder then that many film stars no
longer want to work with her
despite his worldwide success as captain
kirk and star trek
actor william shatner seems to be rather
moderately admired by his colleagues
shatner is said to have fallen out with
almost all of his fellow actors on the
star trek series from leonard nimoy to
george takei
and michelle nichols the main reason is
said to have been the fact that
schaeffner felt neglected and that he
couldn't stand it when
others were the center of attention
altogether he's said to have been simply
unpleasant
smug and arrogant and that is obviously
not a good qualification for making
friends in hollywood
nevertheless he had quite a successful
career and has won at least two emmys
and one
golden globe russell crowe is already
known as a pretty tough guy in front of
the camera and from what we're told that
seems to apply to his personal life to
some extent
as well the new zealander has starred in
many well-known films including la
confidential the insider and of course
gladiator
also it seems to be no secret that crow
regularly underwent spectacular physical
transformations for his roles
for his role in the insider for example
he gained 29 kilos
and shaved his entire head of hair so he
could realistically portray it in the
film
in the late 1990s and early 2000s
however crow made a name for himself
primarily through violence and verbal
outbursts and was even satirized in a
2002 episode of south park called
the new terrence and philip movie
trailer
with movies like transformers indiana
jones and disturber shall above is
indeed no stranger to hollywood
especially in recent years however he
has built up an image among the public
that is
less in his favor mostly he is accused
of simply
being a difficult work colleague on the
set much more serious however
are his physical aggressions for example
on the set of lawless he said to have
gotten into a fight with his colleague
tom hardy and later had an unpleasant
public food with alec baldwin
few months ago it was even revealed that
his ex-girlfriend
fka twix was suing him for charges like
abuse and sexual assault
even though all above the night most of
the accusations he still admitted to
having problems related to liquor and
his
aggression singasia also accuses him of
emotionally hurting her in their
relationship
through pathological lying in the 70s
80s and 90s jeffy chase was a staple in
the us hollywood landscape
even then he was known for being
exceedingly rude and vicious to his team
and caddyshack he reportedly got to
fight with bill murray and years later
he unsuccessfully attempted to become a
talk show host
a role on the television series
community didn't really end on a
glorious note either
as after he left the show out of the
blue he still publicly stepped up and
claimed that he wasn't even a fan of the
show
reacting to this his x-series colleague
joel mchale
mentioned that chase had behaved very
unfriendly and aggressive towards the
team
contrary to many expectations fight club
star edward norton is one of those
actors that everyone thinks twice about
working with
many accuse him of being a control freak
and being unable to act in films that he
himself is not also directing
likewise he did not make a good
impression on the team of 2008
the incredible hulk when he was asked
whether he wanted to take the lead role
he agreed but with the condition of
being able to make
binding changes to the script and that's
exactly what he did because a few weeks
before the
movie was to be shot norton undertook
serious changes to the script which
ended up
in a rather confusing story marvel
executives didn't like the incoherent
focus on dialogue and character
development and logically chose another
candidate for the role of the hulk in
the first avenger film
mark ruffalo
bruce willis career began with his role
in moonlighting alongside civil shepherd
as a funny character he then achieved
global fame with the christmas movie
die hard and of course the sixth sense
over time however rumors began to pile
up that the 65 year old was
anything but a pleasant set partner for
one there was the dispute with director
kevin smith who described working with
willis while shooting cop
out as a gruelling experience even the
expendables co-star sylvester stallone
who incidentally isn't known for
friendly interaction with his fellow
human beings himself
doesn't get on too well with willis
either after he demanded an outrageous
pay raise of 1 million per day of
shooting in part 3.
actress gwyneth paltrow had her first
international success with david
fincher's psychological thriller
7. unlike many others on this list
though her career did not go downhill
after her first major hits but
manifested itself into a stable career
over the years
nevertheless it has been more or less
known for more than two decades that she
is definitely not one of the most
popular starlets in hollywood
if you believe many former set employees
paltrow is a really unpleasant
and extremely callous person in 1998
movie line magazine voted her as the
most stuck-up person in the movie
business
still her film appearances are quite
impressive so at least she can't be
accused of being untalented
like many others she simply lacks a bit
of social skills
to conclude this episode we'd like to
give you a quick rundown of a few actors
that others would definitely want to
work with again
and many relevant magazines and forums
names like tom hanks keanu reeves of
course
wolverine lead actor hugh jackman the
sopranos actor james candelfini who
sadly passed away in 2013
mark hamill mark ruffalo chris hamsworth
and
many more come to mind which actors do
you guys think
no one wants to work with anymore and
should we make another extra video about
the most
popular actors feel free to write it
down in the comments
[Music]
foreign